[Music]
m
[Music]
[Music]
as for
the countries that are taking
unfriendly steps towards us towards us
towards economy
they are
asking their own citizens to dress up
warm
and to
tighten their belts
um
saying
about the
that the reason that their conditions
are deteriorating is because they're
imposing sanctions on us
so this is a quite a strange situation
today i heard that ceasefire
is linked by the russian federation to
the implementation
of
the demands
put by president putin to ukraine in
connection to this i would like to
confirm
once again that ukraine
has not surrendered
is not surrendering and will not
surrender the stuff that you're hearing
about uh
chemical weapons this is straight out of
their playbook they start saying that
there are chemical weapons that have
been stored by
their opponents or by the americans and
so when they themselves deploy uh
chemical weapons as i as i fear they
they may they have us a a sort of a mask
you're of cour a fake story ready to go
and you've seen it in syria uh you you
saw it in even in the uk
i i just note that that is what they're
they're already doing it is a cynical uh
barbaric uh
government i'm afraid
you